لا باس من حديث مبهم عن هدنه لكن لا قول
صريحا بوقف الحرب على غزه تماما والشروع
في عمل دولي ينهي الاحتلال ويقيم الدوله
الفلسطينيه وينهي الصراع فشغل الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه الاكبر خلال جوله بلينكن الخمس
في المنطقه هو هو لم يتغير اطلاق اسرى
اسرائيل لدى حماس ولا باس في سياق المسعى
الدبلوماسي الامريكي من حديث غامض عن حل
الدولتين وحل الدولتين هو الترنيمه التي
تزين الخطاب الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
والاوروبي على مدى عقود انها عباره سهله
لا تكلف عملا ولا تلزم احدا بشيء مجرد
قول
انها الصوره الحالمه لدولتين امنت
سعيدتان في سلام جنبا الى جنب اكثر من
سبعه عقود لم يفتر خلالها الغرب من نزج
حكايه الدوله الفلسطينيه ثم نقضها ثم
العوده اليها كره اخرى في لعبه بلاغيه لا
صله لها بالسياسه
العمليه الله اكبر الله اكبر في سياق هذه
الوعود الفارغه كانت التجربه الفلسطينيه
في مقاومه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تدرك ان
التاريخ قليلا ما اسلم نفسه للتسويات
المجانيه وكثيرا ما كان تعبيرا عن فعل
القوه في الحياه تحرير الارض الفلسطينيه
لن يكون استثناء تلك كانت عقيده المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وعقيده كل مقاومه وحركه تحرر
وطني على مدار التاريخ وهي المقاومات التي
س يكون قدرها دائما ان توصف من قبل القوى
الاستعماريه بانها ارهابيه
وتخريب اليوم وبضغط من حرب اسرائيل على
غزه الحرب الاطول في تاريخ التجربه
النضالي الفلسطينيه والاكثر تكلفه وباث من
صدمه طوفان الاقصى التي لما تفق بعد
اسرائيل منها يعود العالم مرغما للحديث عن
حل الدولتين وعن اله
وعن تبادل الاسرى وعن امكانيه العمل لحل
الصراع وعن ضروره العمل على تطويق نيران
الحرب فلا
تتوسع في تصورنا وجود لاسرائيل مستوعب
داخل الاقليم مع ضمانات امنيه من جيرانها
وشركائها هذا مع وجود اطار زمني عملي لا
يمكن الرجوع عنه يفضي الى دوله فلسطينيه
تعيش جنبا الى جنب مع اسرائيل
ولكن ماذا عن اصل الصراع الذي لا يريد
الامريكيون والغرب رؤيته اذا فاننا ندعو
المجتمع الدولي لتحمل المسؤوليه لفرض وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار فقد ان الاوان لموقف
دولي حازم ضد هذه الحرب المدمره اصل
الصراع ببساطه هو الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للاراضي الفلسطينيه وحرمان الشعب
الفلسطيني من حقه في دولته وعاصمتها القدس
المحتله التحليل للاحداث التي تشهدها
المنطقه سيرد كل شيء الى الاحتلال طوفان
الاقصى اصله في الاحتلال والحرب المتوحشه
على غزه والتعهد بالقضاء التام على حماس
ودفع الفلسطينيين الى المهاجر المختلفه في
راي اليمين الصهيوني الديني
والسياسي اصله في الاحتلال اضطراب الملاحه
الدوليه في بحر العرب وفي البحر الاحمر
اصله في الاحتلال اصله في الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه
اصلها في الاحتلال نفسه وما كان لجبهه
لبنان ان تنفتح على اسرائيل لولا الحرب
على غزه التي اصلها في الاحتلال بل ربما
كان للجنود الامريكيين الثلاث ان يموتوا
بقصف القاعده الامريكيه في الاردن لولا
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وهذا ايضا اصله
في
الاحتلال المنطق البسيط يقول ان سلام
المنطقه وحروبها كامن في الا
ينتهي الاحتلال ينتهي الصراع ما الذي
تستطيع ان تفعله اداره بايدن اليوم مما لم
تستطع انجازه في ايامها الفتيه لا شيء
فباي دن ونتنياهو كلاهما ضحيه سياسيه
للحرب يدخل بايدن الانتخابات الرئاسيه
باقل رصيد من الانجازات ولن يجرؤ على عداء
اللوبيات اليهوديه في امريكا باغض اسرائيل
او حملها على ما لا تريد اما نتنياهو فهو
ليس اقل منه ورطه فحياته السياسيه اصبحت
معلقه بحرب غزه والاستمرار فيها استمرار
بلا نصر الا قتل الالاف من الشعب
الفلسطيني فلا الرهائن حرروا ولا حماس
اختفت بل برزت القضيه الفلسطينيه تضغط على
العالم كله كما لم تفعل من قبل باعتبارها
قضيه هي في حدها الاقصى اكثر من دنه ووقف
حرب انها قضيه دوله غائبه يجب ان تقام
وشرط قيامها انهاء الاحتلال تلك هي
القضيه